so william thomas was a college summer
he was pretty good then he decided
pretty smart to identify as a woman and
he became great
not a scam or anything and now he's been
nominated by university of pennsylvania
which is sort of an heavy league school
as the quote ncaa woman of the year
so here you have a man competing in
women's swimming competitions and
getting
awarded for it now riley gaines also
competes for the university of kentucky
as a swimmer she is a woman she's also
been nominated to be the ncaa woman of
the year he joins us tonight riley
thanks so much for coming on would it
just be easier to identify as an eighth
grader and just dominate kids swimming
yeah right that sounds about
like how it's going doesn't it
yes it does i'm sorry to make fun of it
but i don't know what else to say how do
you feel you've been nominated what it
is
yeah that's exactly what it is it's a
mockery that's that's what this whole
thing has turned into
something we've as female athletes
dedicated our whole lives to it's
something that people are laughing at um
it's an insult it's incredibly
disheartening
and quite frankly it's wrong
well especially since swimming is i ask
any swimmer it's got to be the most
painful of all sports i mean pain
tolerance is one of the key
qualifications for collegiate swimming
right the ability to endure a lot of
suffering in the pool so you spent years
enduring this and some guy jumps ahead
of you i mean are you bitter about it
i mean we have an ncaa woman of the year
who spent 95 percent of their life as a
male
that just it doesn't add up it's a it's
incredibly just
insulting think of all the athletes at
upenn the deserving female athletes who
did not get this nomination and thomas
did after quite literally only one year
woman of the year it makes sense because
it's been one year thomas has spent as a
female
um and so yeah it's insulting it's a
punch in the gut it's a it's a slap to
the face and it's a total regression of
what title ix stands for um and
ironically enough i brought this it's a
letter i got from the ncaa today
i got it actually as i was walking out
of the door to come to the studio but i
picked it up um
it says
that this award is rooted in title ix
i'll just pause there for a second
um
it's rooted in title ix and as the 50th
anniversary of title ix this year's
instillable ncaa woman of the year award
provides an important opportunity to
honor incredible women and reflect on
the impact of women on intercollegiate
sports and i just read this and honestly
like you said i just laughed because
that's that's what we're doing at this
point is laughing at women
it's funny because obviously universal
pennsylvania is a joke and has been for
a while most people don't know that yet
do you find it interesting that the the
kentucky where you go
has taken a stand for biology where this
quote ivy league school
is taking a stand against biology
yeah for sure i think it says something
about the southeastern conference
it says a lot obviously about the ivy
league but for them to nominate me
obviously at the university of kentucky
we have amazing female athletes
we have abby steiner who's a u.s
champion we have ryan howard who's the
number one wnba draft pick and so i
don't want to say i feel undeserving
because i've accomplished great things
as well but i do think that this is um
a little bit strategic on both parts
yeah
i think the takeaway for parents is if a
choice between sending a kid to penn or
kentucky choose kentucky in a second i
appreciate you coming on
we are rooting for you riley gaines good
to see you thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight